- Well, that's why this
next part is so unbelievable
and also infuriating.
Two of your books were banned
by a school district in Pennsylvania.
Children's books.
- I mean
- Two children's books.
But I'm like where, what year is it?
- Right. So
- I was like
(laughing)
- and you should see my house.
So, I'm on Twitter
and all of a sudden someone tells me
they're like "Brad they
banned 'I am Rosa Parks'
and 'I am Martin Luther King Jr'."
I'm like, you know, I
mean, look at these, you,
this is clearly trying to like,
do some harm here, right.
- Clearly you're trying
to just destroy villages.
Yeah.
- My wife, my wife was so pissed.
My wife is like, I'm gonna kill 'em.
And I'm like, yeah, but I was heartbroken.
Right. She's murderer.
- Right? Yeah.
- Yeah. You know our house
now it really is true.
- That's a good yin and yang
you have going on there.
- But I was
But the truth was I was heartbroken
cuz like there are all these kids
that don't get that story now.
- Yeah.
- And when you look at that,
I'm like, that's just crazy.
Cuz I don't care where, I know
race is a hard subject, but
- But when you shield them
from it, nothing progresses.
- God bless. Right.
- Yeah.
- I mean the, I tell my kids all the time
I know it may be hard.
You don't shy away from it.
The only way is you gotta go through
and we do our kids a huge disservice
if we don't discuss these issues.
- And we do ourselves
because the next generation
you're not helping them, yeah.
- That that's it.
And, and these books are
literally designed to
give your kids these lessons.
I have a, you know, in
the back of every book
there's a real photograph of the person.
So you see this cartoon story.
And, and my friend told me
this story, so he's white,
his daughter's black, adopted.
And he says, he gets to the last page of,
"I am Rosa Parks"
and he opens it and she sees
the real picture of Rosa Parks.
And she says, wait a minute,
this really happened.
This really happened.
And he said and suddenly he was having
the first real conversation
about race with his daughter.
He's like, I'm from a mixed family.
I know I should have this
but this is the book
that they banned Kelly.
And I'm like, you must be kidding me.
So the first thing we did of course,
is we got in touch with local teachers.
We got in touch with, who
were incredible by the way,
no one fights like a teacher.
- Yeah. You haven't met my mama.
- Oh no, trust me, we have similar moms.
Right?
- She's a Leo.
- And, and, and what you know we did
is we did what Rosa Parks taught us to do
and what Dr. King taught
us do, is protest.
We said everyone, all the books
in this, not just our books.
Books by Malala, Sonia Sotomayro,
the Sesame Street book
they banned, our books.
We said, go buy them all and protest.
There were 5,000 kids in that district.
And my goal, I want a every banned book,
for every kid in that district.
Fight back like Rosa Park taught us.
- Yeah.